Hey Youtubers! It's Charlie.
Hopefully you guys have had a chance to see Star Wars - Episode 7 this weekend.
Maybe once, maybe like five times.
But, I thought it would be fun to do a video just about the dark side of the force
and the state of the things in the new trilogy, versus what happened in the past.
We are going to be talking about spoilers from the movie
So just careful for *SPOILERS* if you haven't seen it yet!
We're going to be talking about the Knights of Ren, the Sith, and just the dark side of the force in general.
So I'm going to start with this quote from Maz Kanata -  she kind of sets the stage for what's going on with the
dark side of the force and just evil in
general in the galaxy.
She's about a thousand years old, as told by Han Solo, and says "I've seen darkness take many forms -
the Sith, the Empire, now it's calling
itself the First Order."
Now, the First Order and the Knights of Ren
are two completely different things.
The thing of them is sharing the same type
of relationship that the Sith did with
the Empire. Like the Emperor was part of
the Sith - he created the Empire.
That's why I feel like Snoke is
associated with the Knights of Ren, who
led to the creation of the First Order.
Now obviously there's a lot we don't
know about Snoke. We know less about him than almost any other character right now.
It's kind of the same way after
episode 4, after A New Hope, we really
didn't know anything about the Emperor
either.
Only that Darth Vader, this you know seemingly really powerful evil person, had a master himself.
So in the movie, Snoke says, "Even you,
Master of the Knights of Ren, haven't
faced a test like this before."
Rey has that force vision when she touches the lightsaber that shows her
Kylo Ren's characters surrounded by a bunch
of dark figures.
I think those are the Knights of Ren - the
actual people that are part of the Knights of Ren.
So what I think JJ Abrams has done is
move things away from George Lucas's
reliance on the Sith as a group of dark
side force users.
It's like the way different religions of
of real-world earth describe their
ultimate deity. Like everyone has a
slightly different description different
interpretation of religion. But I still
think it all flows from the same source,
and remember Luke was trying to find the
original Jedi Temple.
Now in the expanded universe, there's
actually a story about the beginning of
the Jedi, but they threw out the
expanded universe, so we can't really use
any of those stories as theory crafting,
like whatever they're doing with this
new trilogy, completely different from
what the comics did with the origin of the Jedi.
So here's my question for you guys, let
me know in the comments below, do you
think that Supreme Leader Snoke and Luke Skywalker, as part of like the arc of the Force in the new trilogy,
are on similar paths. Like their story will get back to the origins of the Jedi and the origins of the Force.
When you look back to the original
trilogy, like what would Emperor Palpatine
have done if he had truly conquered the galaxy and eradicated the Jedi. Would you have seen
a new order of Sith rise up, or would it have remained the George Lucas "rule of two" thing.
In case you guys didn't know too - whenever George Lucas sold Lucasfilm to Disney,
one of his conditions was that he would be allowed input on the new films.
So he gave an outline for the new
trilogy, and it was only read by like the
top three Disney executives. Only three
people at Disney read George Lucas'
plans for the new trilogy. They
ultimately decided to throw that out and
that's when they decided to kind of throw out the expanded universe too - go in a different direction.
You have the Knights of Ren instead of the Sith, you have the Resistance instead of the Rebellion.
I'm actually, I'm fairly fascinated to
find out exactly what was in George
Lucas's outline. But largely, most people
think that it was just more focused on
younger characters. Just like the
prequels were focused on younger
characters. So, by all accounts, I think
the Lucasfilm story group did the right
thing when they got rid of George Lucas's ideas.
I mean they also kinda through the Sith
out in terms of like a bad group of
dark side force users, but now we have
this new group to learn about.
So presumably, in like you know 20 years or
however longer it takes for them to make
a new trilogy, we might even see like a
new interpretation of the dark side of the force.
Make no mistake, episode 9 is not going
to be the last saga film.
They're gonna make a new star wars film
every single year 'til the end of time.
And when I say saga films, i'm just talking
about main trilogy. You have like the
spin-off films like Rogue One, that will be next year.
Those will fill in the gaps between
saga films. And if you guys didn't know
Kathleen Kennedy did say that these new saga films, episodes 7, 8, 9, will follow the Skywalker family.
So when you're thinking about character back stories,
just think about the Skywalker family being very, very important.
I know we're all still wondering who Rey is, and then there's really like a couple of really clear choices.
You know, is she a Skywalker? Is she a Solo?
Is she somebody completely different?
I feel like any direction they go is
fine, because her character so amazing
though that you might not even care by
the time they actually explain it.
Like you'd just be so in love with Daisy Ridley.
That's what I feel like these new films
get right that the prequels did not.
Even if you like the spectacle of the
prequels, like there were some
amazing big scenes in the prequels, some
really cool stuff that happened.
I feel like the characters just weren't
there in the way they are these new films.
But back to Kylo Ren, Master of the
Knights of Ren.
Is there anybody who feels like this new
trilogy isn't all about the redemption
of Kylo Ren? I mean obviously it's a much
bigger story than that, but that's the
central family arc - bring Ben home. And
who else just loves that he's named after Ben Kenobi.
It's a perfectly timed bomb to blow up your heart.
I kept wondering what Kylo Ren's real
name was going to be. You know I was so
happy when I heard Han Solo call that
out. I mean obviously it comes before a
really cry-worthy scene. But, it was such a
perfect moment.
So moving to episode 8 territory, we're
probably going to see a lot more of the
actual Knights of Ren, because Supreme Leader Snoke is going to be finishing Kylo Ren's training.
And as much as episode 7 rhyme visually and thematically with episode 4,
I feel like episode 8 is going to be
uncharted territory. So don't expect it
to follow the story beats of Empire as much as
episode 7 follows the story beats of episode 4.
I am so excited to see what Ryan Johnson
does with these characters.
And Daisy Ridley has actually said that she's read the
episode 8 script, so the script is
done. And they've already filmed again,
you know that place where Luke Skywalker,
where Rey's character finds Luke
Skywalker,
they've already been back there to film
scenes for episode 8. Would you not be so
upset if they just skipped over that
last moment with Rey trying to hand the
lightsaber back to Luke? Like if they just
jumped forward in time three months?
You'd be like, oh my god what happened?
So, I am expecting episode 8 to pick up almost immediately after the end of episode 7.
I know a lot of you guys are asking if Supreme Leader Snoke is connected to Emperor Palpatine.
If Emperor Palpatine was the Emperor of the galaxy, and one of the most powerful dark side force users
of all time, then how could Snoke, albeit you know a very powerful person himself,
have absolutely no knowledge of him.
So I think that in the movies they will
reference Palpatine, but my understanding
based on what JJ Abrams has said, is that Snoke doesn't have any kind of connection with Palpatine.
So that's why I don't think he's Darth Plagueis or anybody from the expanded universe.
I know everybody wanted to know if he
might have been Plagueis, like secretly
some other figure who was behind Palpatine.
I think that he definitely is bigger than
Palpatine, but i think that the context
is very different. I think what JJ Abrams
wants to say is that Palpatine, was just
like a small part of the pie that is the Force. So definitely expect them to reference Darth Sidious and the Sith,
but i don't think that their plans have anything to do with what the Sith were doing.
What I'm probably going to do next
this week, just because, you know,
hopefully most of you have seen the
movie by sometime next week, is I'm
going to do bonus videos for some of the
big characters in the film.
I could spend all day talking about
these characters. They're so awesome.
The new characters way more interesting
than the original trilogy characters in
the movie. So be sure to subscribe to get
everything, and the IMAX gift certificate
giveaway is still going on right now. All
you have to do enter that is be a
subscriber, leave a comment on this
video - real simple.
I'll do a Q&A video really soon where I'll
announce the winner of that. In case you
In case you guys haven't seen it, I did do a full
review of the movie. You can click here
for that, and you can click here for the
"12 Days of Deadpool". Just doing a whole
bunch of Deadpool videos before the new
trailer comes.
Thank you so much for watching, everybody
let's high five, I'll see you guys tonight!